[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of rain Wilson who is incredible
incredible actor an incredible person
and an incredible author whose new book
Soul boom why we need a spiritual
Revolution is out now and it is
incredible let's listen let's let's
listen in for a little taste of what's
to come says I want you to say look in
the mirror and say I am enough yeah can
you do that Pete Holmes yeah that's
great I am enough though
I understand why you couldn't
because because you're not enough
only a couple things to plug up top
before we get back to that wonderful
episode uh this wonderful episode I am
currently touring if you want to come
see me I will be in Milwaukee this
weekend uh Madison Wisconsin although I
believe that sold out thank you Madison
go to peterhomes.com whenever you hear
this if I'm touring which I am currently
uh you will see easy links to the
tickets there easy links the official
link of buying tickets to my show go to
petehomes.com I'm very proud of this
hour uh super excited for you guys to
see it and we're about to film it too so
it'll be out soon but see it live see it
live see it live it's so much better
live uh but you can you know you have a
say you shape it if you laugh you you
respond you're kind of a co-creator of
the hour and then you get to see it on
your TV and go like I was there when
that joke was uh different
[Laughter]
I hope to see you out on the road
um also what else do I have to plug just
one thing which is our friends at the
perfect Gene I'm also wearing look at
this if you're watching the video the
perfect Gene now makes the perfect
hoodie I'm wearing the best fitting best
looking best feeling hoodie and it's
from our friends at the perfect gene
they also have new washes so if you've
heard me do this ad a bunch of times
listen again for the first time they're
now doing khakis khaki perfect jeans
they're doing a lighter wash well I
won't stand up but I'm wearing them
right now it's like a lighter blue which
is now my new favorite pair they last so
long if you don't know they're so
comfortable they're two percent spandex
2.5 rayon which means they stretch so
your nuts ain't crushed I love wearing
soft pants but I couldn't find any that
looked good the perfect jean look like
designer expensive incredible high-end
fashion but they stretch and bend like
their yoga hands it's so cool you could
sleep in them they're that comfortable
you can feel like Sting but look like a
regular human
they're the only pants I wear for real I
give them to our guests give out links
to them we send a link to Neil deGrasse
Tyson I can't I hope you get some
because you need to be comfortable when
you're when you're exploring the
expanses of space and you gotta spare
your Notch the perfect Gene for the
Perfectly Imperfect men and now the
perfect hoodie and also the perfect
khaki 20 off when you use code weirdo at
checkout liberate your lower limbs with
the one and only perfect Gene whether
you're working with lemons or lentils a
big three leaf clover or a hunk and
eggplant the perfect jeans got you
covered take a peat at Peak not a p take
a peek at the perfect
gene.nyc that's the perfect j-e-a-n dot
NYC and use code weirdo for 20 off at
checkout feel great look great and
support this show alright everybody hope
to see you on the road go to pedoms.com
enjoy this chat check out soulboom it's
rain Wilson returns get into it
in my life
be my friend your Debonair and oh so
dreamy
you are more handsome than the
characters you play
have to dress you down and make your
hair real weird because in real life
you're a dream about dream about a
[__] Dreamboat
look at you you look like a you look is
this because you're an author
because you look like it let's get comfy
I wore my art author cardigan Arthur my
author cardigan you were on the Arthur I
played our the character of Arthur on
the Arthur on uh six feet under was my
character was Arthur
make arthas work for a while it's not
artists you were on NBC's The arthas yes
and you played Arthur and I played
Arthur and you're the founder of
um Soul cycle I know you let's just talk
about how you're uncomfortably close to
me this is not how podcasts work
isn't it
you don't do this on Camel I could
cancel you right now [__] I felt
uh wait I can't even make that joke I
was gonna say like I just felt that you
were okay with it but that's not I'm
totally okay with that okay yeah
it should be very fresh
you look I'm sorry but you I want to
paint you right now you can sketch me I
won't let you pay me I would take too
long but if you want to sketch me well
I'll sketch you then you can go home
what's sorry what's your name Katie
Katie do you have a uh a draw pad a
sketch pad
I thought it was going to be something
that'd be great these are for you if you
want this is Magic mine they are a
sponsor but I truly love them it went I
love them and then but you drink it I
want is it a CBD in it nope does it have
caffeine in it just 35 that's like a
weak cup of tea
35 milligrams that's that's strong no
it's tiny for me I'm very caffeine
sensitive okay I used to be a caffeine
addict among all my addictions I used to
literally be a caffeine addict and I
went on a meditate to stop I can do it
myself
because you're almost 60 you don't want
me to open it for you wow it's because
you're nearer to the Grave wow like when
you were in your 20s
hahaha
you I thought humility made it weird you
made it it was one of the ten
one of the ten tenants uh ten tenants
okay but what did you just say
which part that what are the last two
words you just said ten tenants right
that's not the right word
ten principles
10 10 Nets
what'd I say tenants tenants rent a
house
tenets are principles there's no statute
statute of limitations not statue of
limitations and it's not intensive
purposes I'm just joining you in things
that it's fun also to correct people
what's the way can I say yeah what's the
difference pin in that love that you
corrected me because that's love that's
saying you have a blueberry in your
teeth
I say tenants yeah tenants tenets thank
you it drives me crazy it's not a rainy
day go ahead yeah rainy day it's not
espresso no it's espresso and it's not
ironic that your flight just took off
right it's odd or coincidental or
strange or surprising right it's not
ironic right and it's espresso everyone
please because it's fun to feel classy
yeah espresso espresso Martin Scorsese I
don't know and uh regardless and
irregardless mean the same thing facts
and uh bi-weekly meaning twice a week or
every other week same word wow
it's a wonder we're doing as well are we
rolling we really should roll on this
you mean take MDMA
I'm rolling baby
you were addicted to caffeine yes have
you ever done MDMA
no really oh my God
you're gonna love it it's in there I'm
just kidding no no no but um spiritually
speaking as as a you and I I had a drug
phase okay maybe I shouldn't be pitching
this to you but I yeah and I don't do
drugs because I'm sober but I didn't do
it I didn't do Ecstasy or Molly MDMA
whatever that family I see and I didn't
do heroin heroin and I didn't do any
psychedelics yikes so there's a whole
category several categories that I
didn't do this is touchy because you're
sobi noodles and I'm somewhat Sobe
noodles I don't drink anymore
okay you're Hollywood sober I'm Cali
sober yeah yeah I'll occasionally do
weed but I definitely will always and
forever do psychedelics and and as a
spiritual it shows
excuse me why Krasinski
um
you know I make that joke even when
you're not here I say excuse me like
Krasinski do you really he's great at it
it's not even can you close the door
Katie we got some you would have been a
great uh like a brother of Jim with with
some kind of mental it started issues
development issues if you could have
been Jim's
Krasinski and I have fan overlap that
was one of the first things I noticed
was people that like John Krasinski also
tended to like me when I was maybe when
I was younger they're like tall white
guys with sweeping hair swoopy yeah I
got I got the J or like sees one two
three uh gym pokies yeah does that
Pokemon's Pokemon also it's Pokemon not
Pokemon
it's poke Bowl do we want to have a
sustained conversation about it do we
want to talk about caffeine I want to
talk about addiction I love talking
about addiction but okay here's the the
nickel in the pickle
how are we going to get it out without
pickle hands you know what I mean you're
sober and the most we both wrote books
about literally both you and I on our
press tours for our books about
spirituality use the phrase we've thrown
out the baby with the bath that was like
the Cornerstone of my yeah no it's a
great work throughout the spiritual baby
with the religious bath water I used to
say we threw baby Jesus out with the
bathwater just to kind of yeah be funny
yeah because of all the deities only one
was really famous as a baby right maybe
Krishna but you see what I'm saying yeah
but what brought me back the Infant of
Prague
huh the Infant of Prague I know he said
look look it up there is a saint that
isn't you go to Prague and there's all
these babies everywhere and little
statuary of this little baby holding a
holy Roman rattle it's the Infant of
Prague idly Roman rattle the Kings of
Leon song
Holy Roman rattle
tell me so he's a deity yeah the Infant
of Prague I don't know what his magic
powers are but okay he's floating and
yeah well let me put this Nickel in the
pickle back back again because I took it
out and like okay it's sweet pickles
bread and butter spiritual baby with the
religious bath what I'm saying is you
and I are uh soldiers for Christ I'm
gonna say no you and I are on the same
page meaning hey everybody there's
something that we've lost big time yeah
and I love your book and you're making
the case at like depression and and and
meaninglessness and purposelessness is
is not just like an idea it has real
life ramifications on our lives today
correct like what we how you feel today
how you live everything and it goes back
to these meaning making yeah systems now
here's the nickel and the pickle I came
back to mine because I took uh
psilocybin and that's interesting to me
does it tickle your nickel
well I have a section here's my
unpopular opinion of the day where I my
opinion runs a hundred percent contrary
to contemporary thought especially in
secular Urban America I have to go to
the minerals
the perfect Gene they're so stretchy the
perfect Gene at NYC can you just give me
one second go ahead how do you run how
do you run away from the popular
um do you think Alex are dumb I I think
psychedelics are dumb you've never done
them right that would be like I'd be
like strawberries tastes like [__]
I've never had a strawberry that's but
that's that's not what I'm talking about
because I can I don't have to do yes I
want you to feel safe I don't feel like
I have to I've I see how the podcast
works now I just need to start talking
and you're gonna talk and I'm just gonna
just I'm not res Aslan baby I got a lot
to say you do I got a lot to say I'm
gonna say it no I just want to make sure
you feel supported and safe this is a
safe place uh yeah it doesn't matter if
it's safe or not I like that I don't
need safe spaces sorry and are you that
Idris Elba character where you have
those guns and he loads them real fast
because you're smooth as [__] so I
don't I don't know what that nobody does
Stephen King made it keep going wow okay
oh yeah the Gunslinger yeah yeah um no I
I don't have to have done something to
know that it's a bad idea do you know
what I mean there there that the world
doesn't work that way so here's my issue
when I was a kid in the 70s my uncles
along with a lot of people that I met
were in the uh Andy Rooney Andy Leary
Timothy Leary you know drop in tune out
LSD will change your life yeah mode and
that went on for a long time I'm young
I'm old enough to remember that because
I'm almost 60. so
uh then in the 80s my friends were doing
like peyote and then it was like
mushrooms and mush hey we're gonna do
mushrooms is going to change your life
and what were you saying to all these
invitations I I just wasn't I was too
scared to do psychedelics because I
thought I would lose control and poop my
pants and and my my best friend John did
it and saw demons and was sobbing and
[__] himself in the in on on Tom in
Thompson Square Park in New York City
and saw the the face of the devil for
hours and was sobbing and [__] himself
so I was like yeah I don't I don't want
to do that not a good commercial so
um you know they bronze those turds
they're still in the park no kidding
yeah the devil turds but I'm gonna put
that aside and just say the the the new
trend toward Ayahuasca and ibogaine Etc
and this kind of quote-unquote plant
medicine which first of all why are
psychedelics plant medicine and heroin
and cocaine which come from plants not
plant medicine it's all drugs it just
affects your brain differently let me
finish
I think you asked a question I think
it's a short it's a it was I it was just
for you yeah it was your viewers
throwing a tennis ball in the air to
catch it I'll let you answer but just
let me finish my point because the point
is is that it's commercialized and
Americanized and very Western to say I'm
gonna take this weekend off from work
I'm gonna fly down to Costa Rica to this
Resort where there's a shaman who's
gonna guide me through my Ayahuasca
journey in the park next to the hotel
and I'm gonna throw up in a bucket and
someone's gonna stroke my hair I'm going
to have this experience and then I got
to be back to work selling Insurance on
Wednesday but I want Enlightenment but
it's got to fit in this four to five day
span right to me that's what I have the
problem with when not traditional
Ayahuasca is used as part of the
ceremonies of a tribe over decades in in
in its in connection with the hunt
with the seasons with a whole universe
and mythology of spirituality it isn't
like shoehorned into someone's work
schedule and that's very American and
commercialized
it's consumers I want God love the
businessman that just has the four days
can't God comes to the hungry in the
form of food but God comes to the
businessman in the form of a two-day
Ayahuasca but you need to the spiritual
transformation and inspiration doesn't
have to be drug-induced and you can
spend you can find 15 minutes every
morning to start to undertake that
experience yes and you can there are so
many other modalities of finding
spiritual transformation and
Enlightenment other than shoehorning in
a psychedelic experience
yeah but so is this expression in India
they go when they saw everything
happening in the 60s and 70s with
psychedelics they're like God it's a
materialist Nation so God came to you as
a material that's like God comes to the
hungry in the form of food I'm just
saying like people come to God a lot of
different ways
yeah how many that well we could talk
about that there's a hmb it'll keep you
what does that mean keep your muscle
mass important at your age
[Music]
Katie's smiled at that one even it's
it's just kidding like wow
I've I value your opinion I think it's
great and we're talking about a
hypothetical businessman I guess
obviously I'll be a there's a little bit
of a a defensiveness on my part because
I'm like I started meditating after I
had a psychedelic experience and that's
because I had a psychedelic experience
was because I realized that there's such
a thing as something ineffable meaning
the Transcendent but you have this but
didn't you have that when you were in
the church
didn't you find that in a church campus
and I stifled a laugh no you did not
absolutely you didn't have a
Transcendent spiritual experience in all
of the church camps and and choir
sessions and service projects that you
undertook in your teenage years and
early 20s no absolutely I read his book
you did
yeah did you say it's a camera please
this is your Kozinski comedy sex guys I
read
I read comedy sex god and I first
started out and I loved it oh it
inspired me well you're beautiful and I
love your book and I I guess this is
weird maybe I have an issue with
conflict but I'm just saying it's a big
it's a big party it's like Jesus says my
my father's Mansion has many rooms you
know what I mean I'm like some people
come to God by doing heroin hitting a
bottom getting broken getting shattered
and getting rebuilt talk to the
alcoholics that was a horrible
experience and it brought so everyone if
you're watching at home try heroin if
you haven't found God hit bottom well I
guess what drink yourself into it this
thing that is that's God and spirit is
only pursuing you if you get on your mat
for 30 minutes every morning here's
here's my problem it's in traffic
there's no shortcuts and I think a lot
of people who do psychedelics are
looking for a shortcut and I just I
don't buy that I don't get with that
it's a long cut it's a life choice and
you don't need chemicals to do it that's
all it's a I told you it's a really
unpopular opinion you are completely in
the realm of the Joe roganification of
the American male in there 30s 40s I'm
44. uh now you can make your jokes 44 is
I guy you wish I would get my left leg
to be 44 again but then you'd be I guess
you'd be happy I would hop around in my
40s and feel [__] great yeah no I
like my voice so it's a really unpopular
opinion I understand that in the
comments of the YouTube channel it's
gonna I'm gonna get lambasted for it no
you won't that's I there's a lot of
people that agree with you I don't know
Brian murarescu who wrote the
immortality key which is about the the
Psychedelic origins of all things going
back to Ellie uses in Greece you've
heard of this sure he hasn't done
psychedelics he doesn't he's not
interested he finds his Transcendent fix
in other ways the trick is like
it's a long and cold and dark night
let's take not just psychedelics
I think God is looking for us
do you see the power move that was good
when you're writing when you're writing
your book you had to feel that that flow
and that connection when you were
merging in an ensemble like the office
like I'm just saying why put up any
fence post and and what I'm bristling at
is God comes to the good the discipline
the worthy the people that go this is a
long haul I'm actually think the way
that I see it it's not it's not that's
not what I'm saying I'm talking about
capitalism I'm talking about
here is a convenient superficial
shortcut where I can take this amount of
time off of my schedule go plug in to
have this spiritual experience and to me
it's very American and it's very and God
met us there yeah but I to me that's the
part of America and Western culture that
I I find revulsion I agree so it's great
because it's consumers isn't it
superficial and I want to buy this
experience and we can't stop falling
upward rain I'm not even saying just
psychedelics I'm saying we're all full
of [__] I have that that humbling with
my practice all the time that I kid
myself that I'm coming to God because I
desire the truth how much of me just
doesn't want to get hurt how much of me
just doesn't want to be wrong how much
of me doesn't want to be a fool or go to
some old school Looney Tunes hell
there's so much self-service and God
doesn't say you know what this is pretty
capitalistic I'm not saying God is
judging people that do psychedelics I
think you're you're I'm just saying that
culturally we're not having this kind
we're only now having this conversation
this conversation isn't being had out
there about the short-term consumerist
mindset of I'm gonna buy a resort
weekend Transcendent experience that
conversation needs to be had I don't
think God is judging you or anyone who
does Ayahuasca it has a trip and opens
doors in there why aren't we imitating
that why aren't we entertaining that
that's not human I have strong opinions
about right and wrong and ways to do
things and that also might rub people
the wrong way I think that for instance
I think I think morality is a thing yeah
in Contemporary American culture
morality is a dirty word people don't
want to talk about morality like the
idea that there's a a right and wrong
that might come from a place other than
what's societally socially agreed upon
yeah is is an anathema to kind of
liberal values to Marxist post-modern
values certainly and I'm a little bit
with Jordan Peterson on the whole idea
of morality which
um so you know I have strong you can say
that do you have my face sewn in the
inside of your jacket remember when he
was on Rogue and he was like I have your
face Joel I have your face sewn on the
inside of my jacket why didn't we talk
about that for 20 minutes Jordan's just
going around with comedian faces I have
huge problems with him and now he's
holding off he's lecturing people on
climate change and like going contrary
to like science and climate change and
it's like well what about CO2 it's
increased CO2 all over the world because
of climate change because plants are
healthier but no one's studying that
like dude yeah I understand yeah I I
can't even I'm not sitting that out
because it's not popular to talk about
Jordan Peterson I have an opinion I'm
just that's out of my depth but I think
but I think where we differ here is that
one plant's Stakes about what is and
what isn't acceptable to oneself and one
can also criticize contemporary culture
and Society I'm not not seeking to
emulate God who is all forgiving all
loving and all-accepting of everyone I
have issues with lots of things I have
issues with materialism and and
capitalism and consumerism right and how
that reflects in like goop right as a as
a phenomenon right and how it reflects
in kind of new age people and how new AG
people kind of try and find
Transcendence that I find very
narcissistic and Naval Naval gazing so I
have judgments and I'm not I would never
meet a new age person or someone who had
done psychedelics and say I'm condemning
you or I'm judging you or I'm looking
down on you that's not what I'm saying
at all but I do think that there are we
should strive to find ever more pure and
ever more enlightened paths towards
being better and better people and
building a better and better culture
we'll get to that that's interesting
that's I I get it
I get it what I was going to interrupt
you and you and you skillfully didn't
allow me hey you're also wearing bombos
but you know what I just thought you
liked my bombas you put them in
backwards and I was like what the hell
like does it really matter there's those
are Sam Moss Sabbath oh you know that
you know the bombas colors those are but
that's bombas backwards
I thought you were saying it's sand Moss
yeah it was the greenish color of the
sock no no I know all our bombas got
mixed up some very often wearing one of
mine and one of Val's I guess what I'm
saying is Val is his dead mother
I love it's like the Vanessa Vanessa
bear I love that for you and also I love
the business guy who [__] sucks
because we're making them up we can make
them as as much as we want I know I know
I have someone in my mind I'm saying
he's Robin Williams in the first active
hook he's a yuppie he doesn't like his
kids and he doesn't have time for God
how
I guess I'm just like
Jesus has this line where he says if
you're not he actually says both he says
if you're not for us you're against us
but he says if you're not against us
you're forced it's in two different
gospels he contradicts himself but I'm
saying like
this little willingness of the
businessman which actually ends up being
greater than he even intended going to
this thing and I know you haven't done I
haven't done Ayahuasca either but from
everyone I've talked to it's a real
Walnut cracking it's not an Escapist
drug it's a it's a confrontational
experience over that you do over three
days and it breaks you and and you need
guidance and you need to be reintegrated
and stuff so this guy sure maybe he is
just like a dot-commer or an
entrepreneur that's with the trend and
that's groovy like like succession
he's uh Gojo he's the Gojo guy yeah
I'm just the reason I'm nudging you
towards just a loving acceptance of that
person's tiny flicker of their internal
flame it's almost gone in virtual
reality porn and cocaine and whatever it
is however awful this person is but
there's this tiny Flicker and and even
not his conscious mind goes I'll do
Ayahuasca there's something deeper in
him you could say his soul that is going
like [__] yeah we're gonna have this
[__] for four days we're gonna
get at him that's what I'm saying God
came to us as a material God comes as to
as a conversation God comes to us you
know I've had religious experiences
doing nightclub comedy talking about
jizz and [__] and I'm like
that the so let me just stick The
Landing the reason I'm nudging you
towards that is if I judge that guy I
really do feel like I'm just so I don't
judge that guy yeah I don't judge that
guy and this is the difference it's like
I have dozens of friends that have done
Ayahuasca and and psychedelics and had
transformative experience and I just hug
them and I'm like [__] that's great
man good for you I love you that's
amazing tell me about it what did you
learn that's amazing right so here's the
difference is how do we have like I
don't have any Judgment of any
individuals that have taken that path
I'm just saying collectively for decades
we have thought of psychedelics as a
portal to a kind of a a shortcut to
spiritual enlightenment and it hasn't
really worked it hasn't really been
working and I actually know some
relatives and some friends who uh
through micro dosing or or depend
tendency
fried their brains and [__] themselves
up yeah and so there's there's there's
some there's some perils there that
aren't really discussing underreported I
agree it's it's underreported the
addiction issues around it Paul Simon
wrote about it in his biography which is
excellent he had I walk he snuck and
stole and grew his own Ayahuasca and was
like taking it daily and he talked about
how he had a dependency issue and he
regrets it and he he took it away from
its kind of sacredness yeah so I would
never judge someone individually but I
do think collectively I'm just asking us
Americans to strive for more than
anything as a as a shortcut and for me
I've had spiritual experiences on stage
I've had uh in in acting uh absolutely I
think through ART in nature
um and and and frankly I struggle to
have them in my daily life in Los
Angeles and I struggle and I'm not very
spiritual most of the time yeah I I have
to meditate and do cold plunges and
exercise and journal and make calls to
my 12 Step Brothers I have to do that on
a daily basis just to get to kind of
functional yeah I understand so it's I
don't I'm not arrived you know Julia
Cameron once said I come to spirituality
not out of virtue but out of necessity
so for me because of addiction mental
health issues whatever I needed to find
a spiritual path a long-term spiritual
path to kind of keep me moving in the
right direction I am not Holier or more
arrived or awakened
Buddha's the awakened one I'm not more
awakened than than anyone else it's just
I it gets me to functional I hear that
yeah I was wondering what the that was
one of those questions I scrawled here
I'll give a tease you don't want to look
at that I'm just kidding it just says
one kid Galaxy Quest Nicaragua dad
that's all it says good
um because you've done the show before I
we covered the basics yes you know so I
was just kind of looking for things we
haven't talked about but I was drawn to
religion or Spirit really religion
um which led to spirituality
um but because there was so there was no
uh my household was a little tumultuous
it was a it was a tropical Zone a lot a
lot of Storms and a lot of uncertainty
and I loved that church was a place
where people were under a code agreed to
be kind yeah that's one of your tenets
yep is compassion yeah kindness yeah so
before we launch off the deep end and I
do want to talk to you about non-duality
and and how that kind of applies to some
of the things because that was one of
the just a tease where I think we'll go
that was one of the perspectives that
wasn't really represented in the book
that I found was vedanta but before we
get to that I went that's the whole
ending of the book is it yeah it's the
whole that's how I end I stick the
landing on vedanta really yeah that
where the illusion of separateness well
then I can't wait to talk about it I
love it right after these minerals you
see how I can stretch these jeans so
easily these are called the perfect Gene
those are corduroys and they can't they
stretching they're gonna they're gonna
rip we're gonna he's gonna be canceled
for that
um so I loved going to a place where
where kindness was like an agreed upon
communal quality obviously not everybody
did it all of the time but it was a safe
place it was one of the first places I
performed and I just liked that
everybody defaulted to listening sharing
honesty caring kindness yeah helpfulness
you could use a little more of that as a
podcast host
all right frankly
oh I love it so tell me so for me it was
a a feeling of a lack of control in my
in my house my parents did the best they
could but I was like these people don't
like each other I wrote in my book that
they were like Greek gods throwing
lightning bolts yeah you can't just go
two grown-ups are having an altercation
you're like the world is ending so I
really craved my youth pastor like I
loved him yeah he was so cool yeah and
the regular Pastor I just loved all that
so psychologically that is sort of what
drew me in those doors and then I also
was as I said in my own book a real what
is this kid I was going around going
like what is water I know hydrogen and
oxygen but like what is hydrogen and
what is oxygen how deep can we go how
far out can we go like what is this and
and what is it that knows what this is
like isn't that crazy that there's an
awareness that can hear you and
Consciousness yeah people talk about how
the ear works and they talk about a
little bit of liquid and a crystal and
I'm like but what hears it I know what
filters the sound and gives it to the
brain but what in the brain goes rain is
here yeah [__] crazy so I've always
been that kind of kid yeah tell me the
kind of kid you were what what brought
you into bye
[Music]
um that's called uvulating did you know
manipulating I love that I know the term
uvula from King's Quest 3 where you get
swallowed by a whale and if you have a
feather in your inventory
you have to type tickle uvula but the
game teaches you what a uvula is because
you go like tickle whale and it goes
like where so you said something in that
really beautiful share that you had that
uh here's another really unpopular
opinion
uh because this is an unsafe space
um you said my parents did the best they
could and people always say that about
their parents like their parents did the
best they could and then but I I want to
just push back on that a little bit but
I don't get into that it's like fun why
is that true because I know my parents
and I think back of my parents and they
were and they were pretty terrible
parents all around my mom left when I
was a year and a half my dad
um was not good at intimacy I check off
Dad
Dad got it
um my stepmom same and uh they were in a
terrible Loveless marriage they knew it
was a Loveless marriage from the get-go
they would fight and rage and break she
would break dishes in the sink and stomp
off and slam doors and hard on you worse
on those dishes
and and people always say they did the
best they can I know in my life Pete I
have not always done the best that I
could I know that there have been
junctures in my life where I could have
done better existent not existential but
just like a philosophical question if
that's what you did wasn't that kind of
the best you could do meaning it's what
you did meaning there were unseen
psychological and circumstantial and
maybe even environmental forces that
stopped you from Tony robbinsing and
being like you know what we are going to
the library so isn't everything we do
kind of by definition it's like saying
God's will if it happened it was God's
will that's that's what God's will is
you can say if we did it that was as
good as we could do isn't that kind of a
cop-out isn't it kind of like absolutely
I'm not sure
what do we want to fault each other but
then why do anything why make any choice
and why why why do anything and so just
because hey this is it's God's will and
I'm gonna take a poop in the corner and
then I'm gonna I think sideswipe
someone's car and not tell anyone about
it and it's okay and I'm just you know
what I mean yeah that was
that was is that your uh was it gray
Prius outside
foreign
no but you know
you know it's an unpopular opinion
because the popular opinion is like
everything in the past is forgiveness we
did the best we could and it's like I
really wish I had done better at certain
points in my life and that's how I learn
and so it is a positive uh aspect of
being a human being that I I move
forward and then I make I hopefully try
and make better and better choices even
though that doesn't have been the case
these feel like life strategies for good
living of Earth human lives because
we're talking about forgiveness it's on
it's on that posted I always reference
it but uh father Greg Boyle when he did
this podcast said forgiveness is
overrated give me mercy so when we look
at our parents sucking it up and believe
me I'm talk about the Enneagram I'm an
Enneagram four split down the middle
with a three but four is love talking
about their pain and moping and all
artists and you know weirdos I want to
figure it out
so Mercy versus forgiveness
forgiveness goes I acknowledge that my
parents could have done better but I'm
gonna let that go Mercy just goes like
what is happening here we're in God's
dream but why are we even replaying The
Archives
Let It Go
because because I think that
um the only way out is through and I had
to do a lot of therapy work about my
resentment at my parents and the trauma
that I suffered at their hands in order
to be free of it and now I hold my
parents in my father who's past my
stepmom and my mom are still alive I
hold them in such love and in such Mercy
because you did that work because I did
that work and we're all seated in the
palm of God's grace and surrounded by
light and that's so beautiful and God
bless them I don't think they did the
best they could I think they could have
done better and I wish they had but if
they could have done better wouldn't
they have done better no because why not
because I know that for myself there's
I've had many times in my life where
I've had two very clear roads like
here's the better path rain you could
just have a little more effort and you
could go down there or you could just
settle for the same old behavior that
has proven false before and wrong before
and steered you off course before and
I'm just gonna settle for that because
you couldn't
no I could have you but you didn't and I
didn't then you couldn't
I could have and I didn't why didn't you
because we have free will
we have free will I agree but I'm also
saying we're not we're not just laughing
about like feathers in the Windstream
let's get up and Jog so that moment
where you don't get up and jump yeah
baby we're having a good chat those
those
newer Tropics yeah camera camera magic
mind magic mind.com slash weird
it's focus more stressful it's got
adaptogens in it that's not a thing
adaptive things are a thing there's
adaptogens are not a thing they help you
adapt it's in the name should you get
this from Gwyneth Paltrow you've [__] on
goop twice my friend and I will fight
you with a fencing sword
um
I'm saying you want to get up and Jog
tomorrow you get up and you go this
bed's too comfy I'm saying that's just
the tip of the iceberg there's all of
this stuff underneath the real reason
why you don't get up to jog uh what are
we even doing here we die one day my dad
was emotionally unavailable I'm hungry
I'm weak I didn't get the nutrition why
did I eat that so you couldn't you
couldn't you couldn't or you would have
you couldn't
Mercy yeah I just I don't I just don't
see it that way I see exactly what
you're saying and I think it's a cop-out
it is a cop-out yeah why do we want to
cop on I want to cop on because I want
to be a better person nonsense and I be
a better person
out I'm a better person than I was 10
years ago and I'm a better person than I
was 20 years ago I hear that this is
from choices that I've made and work
that I've done over the Long Haul and
I'm not just up because we were being
blown about because you were able to
those times you made the right choice
you were interesting what do you think
listeners I'd love to hear from you
let's see in the comments his
anti-psychedelic stance magic Minds I
have a lot more unpopular opinions I
love your unpopular opinions and I'm
also loving this zesty conversation but
I I let's go back to your original
question for me I I love what you shared
um so I grew up a member of the Baha'i
faith I grew up that way and what was
what has been difficult for me to wrap
my head around in his been a lifetime of
kind of
praying meditating journaling
therapizing about is the fact that the
Baha'i faith is all about Universal love
and unity and acceptance of all the
faith traditions and healing racism and
sexism and income inequality through
spiritual tools many of which I bring up
in my book Soul boom why we need a
spiritual Revolution I'll talk about it
if Pete won't
um I'll say it in the intro
um you know you know I just how is that
me by the way
um
he's had these really knobby those
aren't knobby that's knobby that's a
little now that's not the AF can I say
something say that I think it looks
great thanks so for me what was
difficult or what was interesting was uh
what was traumatic and it was kind of a
spirit and a lot of people have
religious trauma right and people and
this is part of why we've thrown the
spiritual baby out with the religious
bath water is that people have religious
trauma I was doing a movie with this
director uh who's passed away Roger
Michelle brilliant director in England
and he's like so I understand that you
believe in God and and then you have a
religious faith and spirituality and I'm
like yes and he goes I don't and I was
like oh Roger why is that and he's like
well every day I was dragged to mass and
I had to fold the outfits and I had to
light the incense and I had to mop the
locker room and
you know whatever kids do at math and my
parents would drag me there five days a
week I never believe in any of that it's
like
and he was unable to see that his
religious trauma had then trumped that
whether or not his parents dragman Mass
has nothing to do with the fact of
whether there is a God or not right is
it zero correlation between those two
things and even him as brilliant as he
was he was unable to see that that there
was a distinction between the two so my
religious trauma my specific one was my
parents being in an unhappy Loveless
marriage filled with fighting
and and desperately and deeply believing
in a faith that's all about love and
exception acceptance and healing and
unity so there was this kind of just
giant disconnect between life at home
and life as a Baha'i kid singing Kumbaya
and singing along and I think a lot of
people have had that kind of uh
experience trying to walk the line
between interrupting but also with you
no no tell me is there anything worse
that's not that's my family's Church
portrait over your shoulder over there
and it was worse it kind of gaslighty
yes gaslighting to see the Khaki
button-down version of our family yeah
where we would do an impression of
happiness and not so well put and then
go home and I was it it was a church
cliche that you're in the parking lot
and now it's like get the [__] out of
you know what I mean right and I'm like
what kind of message is this I remember
I remember there was a high gathering at
our house house which they call
firesides where you're like talking
about Baha'i spiritual ideas and there's
going to be prayers and some cookies and
stuff like that and my my stepmom made
tea for everyone and set out the cookies
and made sure everything was laid out
and people were kind of settling and
then she had been really upset about
something that happened earlier with my
dad as she often was stomped across the
living room
went and this was her always her thing
and went into the bedroom and slammed
the door as loud as humanly possible and
there was like one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand and my dad
was like okay well shall we settle down
and say some prayers and maybe do a
meditation and
everyone please uh welcome thanks
there's cookies that and I'm nine years
old or 11 years old or whatever like how
do you process that yeah buddy can I
I'm not projecting on to you this is me
and my addiction one of the things I
liked about booze was it told you what
it was I I don't mean marketing like
good times at the beach you want to be
slick with the ladies have a martini not
my experience you know that's how you go
like hey it's terrible but I liked that
alcohol went in and did the same thing
every time there was something I'm I
don't drink alcohol anymore I don't
think it's evil I'm just saying it's not
for me so this isn't with romantic
hindsight I'm just saying when I when I
had experiences where prayer meeting was
at our house or whatever it was and as
soon as it was over or before it had
started we're having our own experience
of that
of course I would be drawn to caffeine
nicotine alcohol that pretty is pretty
consistent and doesn't really ask much
of you yeah this does sound like our
sponsor is Anheuser-Busch but you know
what I mean it's a winnable game put
this in your mouth and it'll do this to
you for the most part well um so my
alcohol use was uh so you put that so
little boy me little boy rain and Mom
leaves when he's a year and a half
to have an affair blah blah blah I stay
with my dad he gets remarried to in this
unhappy marriage with the Stepmom that I
described little boy rain is in that
milieu for a very long time and uh grows
up with just tremendous anxiety just
like a a a shattering anxiety bouncing
around like a Pachinko ball in my chest
and and then what do I do when I start
when I understand when I start I I don't
drink because Baha'is don't drink
alcohol right or use drugs so until I I
don't drink until about 20 21 and I
start drinking and all of a sudden I
drink if I have three beers my anxiety
just goes away and like this is I didn't
know it at the time I wasn't being
conscious about it in that way but I
used alcohol the same way someone would
use cough syrup if you've got a cough
I'm medicated my anxiety
pretty effectively for years by using
alcohol almost every single night to
help me sleep and it was working until
it wasn't working right and so if that's
the problem I think with drugs and
alcohol is they're often used to
medicate soothe escape the pain of being
a human being yeah food too you have
this feeling and distraction on the
phone I would say the guy that climbed
El Capitan was also going like there's
some [__] I can't feel meaning virtuous
things also can be used or or are a
byproduct of them can also help us not
feel things also to that I say I get it
it's a long and strange journey and and
we need help but when you can't the
question that that a therapist asked me
and that I try to it goes what are you
unwilling to feel right now like what
what is so and a really powerful Mantra
I know you love spiritual hacks is if I
feel this way the rest of my life that's
okay is a very very powerful um brain
it's like pouring a bottle of water in
your on your laptop yeah just fries it
you're trying to run this anxiety
program and you just go you know what if
I feel this way the rest of my life
that's okay yeah because as you know
it's that resistance that that's
actually giving it the charge that's
giving it right the AC DC it's it's
what's running the program yeah yeah no
and then you go it's fine that's really
that's really brilliant and perfect and
I know when when I was starting the
therapeutic process my therapist was
having me say um uh
affirmations positive affirmations yeah
and he printed out a list like from the
internet it was just like Google it had
the ads on it yeah yeah it hit it and it
um check your Equifax check your credit
score and uh and number one on the list
was I am enough and he he handed it to
me and I was like
uh he was like read through this I am
enough well I'm not saying that one he's
like what it's like yeah that's not he's
like well that's the one that you need
to say every day and and it's still one
that I struggle with and I and I am okay
in the struggle yeah really okay like
rain when you wake up in the morning
you're gonna struggle with wondering if
you are enough just as you are and
that's okay to just
to just let that be and
um and in inex in acceptance of that
struggle I I learned that I am I am
enough on a daily basis but he had me
hanging on my bathroom mirror and say it
for 30 days every morning like literally
says I want you to say look in the
mirror and say I am enough yeah can you
do that Pete Holmes yeah that's great I
am enough though I understand why you
couldn't
I'm not
oh
yeah I love it
this Mother's Day I decided to give Val
for real something that was way better
and lasted way longer than a brunch to
say thank you to her for all that she
does for our family we got her her very
own electric e-bike uh because sure you
can do breakfast in bed but why not
instead transform her day-to-day errands
into Fun Carefree mini adventures and
let's be real what moms really need is a
little quality time a little me time to
themselves and electric e-bikes will
take her wherever she wants to go giving
her fun and that craved Solitude is
apparent to be honest we also I got one
for myself because you know we want to
do it as a family and we've got the yep
Maxi seat accessory so Leela can come
along with us because what we're looking
for is something to do as a family that
would get us outside and get us moving
that was fun enough to keep our
four-year-old engaged but also fun
enough to get us motivated to get out
the door and away from the couch and the
TV but the bikes are so comfortable
they're like moving couches they make
errands a breeze and they are so so fun
it's making us enjoy our neighborhood
and nature and fresh air so much and
because they're electric you can roam
freely and reach up to 28 miles per hour
with the twist of a throttle or their
next level pedal assist and they cost
way less than the competition and are
foldable they ship free and come fully
assembled it was awesome it was easy
there's no looking back we are now
electric bike family so celebrate your
mom or yourself and give the freedom
that comes with electric e-bike or visit
uh not ore so to do this not or visit
electric like the word electric without
the e l e c t r i c
e-bikes.com to learn more and to explore
the Epic models electric has to offer
that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com
yeah all right okay what's next our
friends at ritual which is my rich one
why did I say this so weird I'm sorry
timeout if supporting foundational
Health was a sport who would you want on
your team I would choose ritual they
made a multivitamin for men that's based
solely on science and designed to help
fill common nutrient gaps in the diet
with 10 key nutrients I used to go to
the doctor it was a normal occurrence
that they would just tell me I was ready
for it which vitamins I was deficient in
boom ritual fills those gaps I get a
clean hundred percent I just had my
physical bam takes care of it and they
take care of my gut with a pro probiotic
a Prebiotic and a postbiotic all in one
easy to take minty pill scientifically
developed with Mo it's a high quality
key ingredients in clean bioavailable
forms it's uh made traceable because
where your nutrients come from is just
as important as what they are for it's
vegan friendly non-GMO sugar-free
gluten-free and major allergen free
they're Capital as a delayed release
this is key so many people say I would
take a multivitamin but you just peered
out ritual is delayed release so it's
designed to help make it gentle on an
empty stomach and it doesn't break down
until it's in your lower intestine which
helps those vitamins actually get into
your body so it's the only vitamin I've
taken that you don't just immediately
pee out neon green Predator blood and go
well what was the point of that it gets
into your body with a minty Essence and
every bottle keep things fresh and to
make
taking your multis fun and an easy new
part of your ritual so essential for men
is a great multivitamin from a company
you can actually trust and get this
ritual is offering weirdos 10 off during
your first three months so visit
ritual.com weird to start ritual or add
essential for men to your subscription
today and try their Prebiotic their
postbiotic all in one synbiotic plus
it's called Go to ritual.com weird
support your body support the show all
right everybody back to rain Wilson
yeah that's although you know it's funny
no I'm not going to bring up MDMA again
I'm just saying the experiences I've had
on that which are only two in my life
but those they're saying therapeutically
that's one of the things that can
increase is self-compassion
self-understanding and I did it not that
long ago and I had this real I kept
saying novel like I see Pete's gold I
see Pete's gold meaning I can be very
hard on Pete and I even though I can go
he's enough it's not hard enough
hey Krasinski come back oh sorry
I'm now a secret agent isn't he
Chris in I think he's moved past that I
think he's done with that is that over
yeah Jack Ryan yeah I'd rather you not
say the name of it but yeah
here's my Pisces Jack Ryan there we go
Tom's a friend Tom Clancy's Tom Clancy
Tom Clancy's even when that guy has an
orgasm he goes Tom Clancy's
he gets his breakfast in the morning Tom
Clancy's scrambled eggs Tom Clancy's
poop take it easy Splinter Cell nobody
needs this nobody needs it let me ask
you this
because maybe it'll tease us to the last
chapter of your book but
for me ethics even self-love the
underlying issue meaning I'm kind to you
not because uh not even because it it
makes me feel good necessarily or that
it's evolutionary wise and good to have
friends and alliances that's all part of
Pete's story is why Pete's nice to you
but there's a when I'm nice to you it's
because I'm trying to remember and
recognize who you really are so sure
Pete is enough Pete my personality my
ego but who [__] cares really what I
really am
is unborn awareness that that is
timeless we think we're stuck in this
thing where we think like I'm 57 I have
had 57 years [__] [__] like it's
here it's all here and we we tell
ourselves stories longer life
life that are shorter life worse more
pleasure better lots of pain worse but
it's all this it's all it was the whole
thing when it's all said and done will
have been
and the whole point of it to me is to
recognize who we really are who capital
w we really are so when I say I am
enough that's a Rupert spiral book
meditations on I am [__] blow your
dick off if you don't want to do
psychedu dogs which I'm with you just
read Rupert Spira that's that's what's
like you're suggesting for me to blow my
dick off with a big old shotgun because
it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
it's like
[Music]
a YouTuber
I would love to check that out yeah no
Rupert is one of the things you can read
that you actually get into that
Transcendent very very quickly so anyway
all of this is to put it back to you is
now if I say I am enough I'm not even
talking about Pete and that's why I can
say with and I can say I am a beloved
child of God I'm God's treasure I love
that that's written in uh you know Jesse
Eisenberg social network marker on my
mirror I am God's treasure I'm I'm a
huge believer in the The Prodigal Son
being like everybody goes to the Golden
Rule I'm like go to The Prodigal Son
yeah that's the one yeah it's you ran
away you think you left God you
squandered your inheritance your soul
yeah your gift you you and you're Jewish
and you laid down with the pigs so you
were disgraced we can't even really
understand how degraded that was but you
were degraded and Untouchable and
defiled and then you in humility kind of
like a businessman taking Ayahuasca but
in humility you did what you couldn't
you returned to your father and do you
remember what the prodigal son's dad
says he says you were always with me and
everything I have is yours Slaughter the
fat and calf and he loves and celebrates
the son who left and returned more than
the good son who said yeah that's us I
feel like that's it that was Jesus
everyone knows I said that's Jesus's
closer we know he said it that's like
one of the things I feel like everything
else is sort of dicey but I feel very
confident that the prodigal son is the
point and that's who you are you got
lost in with the pigs thinking you were
rain who was not enough in the slot oh
how could I be enough I keep this this
and this and this and this and this and
this and this and then you you broken
and humiliated you go home a lot like
sobriety but you're broken like the 12
Steps you're the cost of admission is
Brokenness not
hello I'm an alcoholic you're not proud
you're broken yeah you go back waving
the White Flag surprise surprise yeah
you don't get forgiven he doesn't say I
know you were with the pigs and I know
you wasted all that money that I gave
you there's just Mercy Jesus [__]
Christ that's it that's who you are
Buddha [__] Christ bahala [__]
Christ Muhammad [__] rain [__]
Christ that's also on my mirror Christ
is in me and where Christ says God is
because Christ is a part of God yeah
that's beautiful man I I I'm I'm all for
that and I think for me I needed to kind
of help heal child Reign that anxious
kid with the slamming doors and the
yelling and the abandon the mom who
abandoned me I needed to kind of like do
some work around that before I was able
to kind of engage in the path that
you're talking about but for me it's
about God so and one of the chapters of
the book I call the notorious God and
it's about a complete kind of
reinvention of how we think about and
talk about God yes so
obviously everyone knows God isn't an
old man with a white beard on a cloud
although my friend although BJ Novak I
did a thing with him and Vijay said
wouldn't it be funny if everyone died
and we went to heaven and there actually
was like an old man with a Long White
Beard and he's like hi I'm God like wait
you're you're like the God on the
Sistine Chapel yeah that was me he
painted me and this is who I am yeah
um Steve Martin beat him to that premise
about oh he did 30 years ago and you
tell him I said that but yeah I'm gonna
tell him that he won't he'll know he's a
brilliant comedy writer I don't think he
thought and I'm the first person to say
this
um yeah it felt like he came up with it
on the moment and made me made me howl
also Kristen Chell did this podcast and
said her God is an old man in the sky
also George Harrison in that documentary
remember he had his he was a very
spacious and free person and he was like
God's not an old man in the sky but God
is also an old man in the sky he was
like it's both that's the space of
paradox but I talked about that in my
book old he's been around man and
unfortunately powerful yeah uh in the
sky not caught in our drama seeing it
from above that's that's why that was a
useful metaphor but go on the
um
the conception of God as a quality like
Beauty for instance
or and I know you've talked about this a
lot before and I've heard you speak
about it like God as love that someone
asked me you know when people say how do
you know you believe in God was like
well I know that I believe in love I
know that I love I don't have to kind of
like go do I love and think about is
that love that I'm feeling like I know
that when I held my infant son who
almost died during childbirth in the
hospital of Van Nuys in the hallway of a
Van Nuys hospital I know that feeling is
love there's and I know that that
sensate that same sensation is the
perfect corollary for the Divine force
that is here with us and in all things
father son you know what I mean yeah
that's going right to it going this is
as close as you can probably go I'm not
saying people who don't have kids don't
know yeah but Jesus constantly going my
father my father and that was because he
was like it's like how you love your
kids right it's like how hopefully you
were loved by right right that that's
that's really found and
um so and I think you you spoke before
about uh Consciousness you know like why
do I hear what is the here what is how's
that sensation like to me the miracle of
Consciousness itself is evidence of of
god-ishness because I'm in the middle I
I perceive that I'm in the middle I'm in
the illusion that I am perceiving the
middle of a 3D movie that surrounds
sound of being rain Wilson experience
and having this conversation and
drinking these delicious Beverages and
remembering my childhood and thinking oh
it's a little cold in here why do they
have that set to 69. I'm wondering
what's going on but it the light is
really beautiful and I hope I get to see
my wife tonight because she was upset
the other day and and this this
incredible way of being we don't need to
have as human beings from the
materialist point of view uh the only
Consciousness that we would need to
propagate the species is one slightly
above gorilla and we don't need to have
poetry in Haiku and reminiscences and
tears of joy and uh and operas and
Radiohead and all of the stuff that
makes us human beings so when I think
about beauty itself as a concept being
closer to God than any kind of beingness
you know David Bentley Hart the famous
Theologian uh talks about like God God
as a being among other beings is the
kind of the first thing we need to throw
away and the uh letting go of any kind
of beingness to God although I can
imagine you saying God is a being and
he's not a being but I would say God is
being and uh but to to remove beingness
from God didn't like the voice you chose
for me either keep going I got a little
effeminate keep going
I liked it listen to my voice you nailed
it
God is that he's that and he's not that
and it's all okay because it's just
things and it is and it just is a love
thing that is and it is accepting it and
that's true but it's also not true and
it's okay because it's true that both
things are just everything is all
together I was quoting George Harrison
keep going but uh
uh so for me like going back to the I am
the whole reason I got into this is like
I am enough and you're absolutely right
and I do stick The Landing in the book
about the illusion of separateness
because that's my illusion of
Consciousness right but as I
seek to find connection
uh and inspiration I see God in all
things and realize that yes I'm having
this illusion of separateness but we're
all waves on the same ocean so on both
things I am a wave
and I'm the ocean that's right so and
sometimes the waves crash back in the
ocean and sometimes the ways waves raise
back up and so I can have an individual
experience as a wave and I can have a
collective experience as an ocean and
both things are true
high five
I was gonna do a foot five but I felt
like that was okay
it's labored breathing on my part that
was uh comedy labor breathing
get them out no
get it on there that's a big old foot
thanks
12 and a half oh 13 over here but oh
well you've got a good four inches on me
true oh he meant that's what she said
okay
love it remember in the British office
do you remember what they said in the
British office instead of that uh they
do say that's what she said but they
also say
as the actor said to the bishop all
right when someone says something right
right naughty naughty or I believe
homosexual okay okay if it was like a a
gay male that's what she said you'd say
that's what the actor said of the bishop
or as the actual sterilize these foam
poofs no you're breathing in pure jld
right who is the last person on the Pod
actually it was Chris gethard
oh Josh Peck
I don't know who that is can you say
that to Cameron we'll email it I don't
know who Josh Peck is he was he was a
Disney star and he's a big YouTuber and
uh he wrote a book called happy people
are annoying which is quite good okay
very interesting guys sober two you'd
enjoy it nice uh not just because he's
so everybody but I love Chris Goddard I
love Chris Goddard
getherd gethered you know when Chris did
the show he was on his way to an office
signing yes I went and saw his signing
with Chris gethard and it was very
I did no I know but you're really
working the get hard get hard get hard
like your marriage is really well done
um no no it was hysterical because no
one recognized him and he signed like
seven headshots and then he was on
social media documenting walking around
the office convention when there was
lines of people to see this series
regulars yes to get signatures and he
was just walking and like and not a
single person was like Hey you were in
the well in the office and he was it was
really funny it was really funny truly
brutes truly brutes I love your ocean
wave uh obviously that's that's an old
not an old I don't mean it like that I
mean like that's a beautiful symbol that
yeah it's metaphor that's probably been
around for ten thousand years yeah
that's probably vedantic innate in
origin that's exactly what I mean and
but it's beautiful when we think about
that's sort of what I'm getting at is
like we add the story a tall wave rain
Wilson's life tall wave you know what I
mean there's there he is like that video
you posted on the plane this guy's
watching the office that's a tall wave
you know what I mean made the news yeah
slow news day slow news day I can't
believe they say that that got it was
kind of crazy on my Instagram it cut
before it got to his screen so I just
thought the guy was one of your co-stars
yeah it it weirdly did that but I the
whole video has me going around and
seeing me on the screen I'm surprised
you didn't go around and everyone
because every time I'm on a plane it's
Everyone's Watching yeah also we all
seem to cope with it talk about three
beer anxiety reduction
I think about this all the time and
again I can find that compassion for us
doing the best we can where I'm like
reality is insane this reality is insane
it's so naked you know what I mean I
could say anything there could airplane
engine could fall on us we could have
Cardiac Arrest all these different
things and we go back specifically to
the office shows like the office which
is like Cheers Cheers was like a place
where your friends were oh everybody
you make that up I'm just making it up
right now and there are
said the actor to the bishop
[Laughter]
comedy and profundity yeah that's the
name of this show so ocean tall wave
analogy yeah the illusion of the tall
wave I had something else but it was
about the office oh remember I was about
to say that I feel like watching the
office was everybody's Xanax yeah the
lockdown in particular which has to feel
kind of good I mean I watched it feels
really good I have a separate rain
you know what I mean yeah I don't I
don't confuse you right I'm just saying
in fact that it doesn't even feel
strange to be talking to you right now
but there's Dwight is also in my life
like those guys are all in my life can
you watch it because it's it would be a
shame to not the whole country you know
what happens for me when I watch the
office and this every shot of memory
this is going to be
close very close put a pin in that yeah
this is going to be what's clipped and
highlighted from our interview do you
know what
happens to me when I watch the office
tell me is I go holy [__] I'm 57 I'm
almost 60. I don't remember anything
about shooting any of that
we will shoot there will be a scene
where Dwight is pushing a shopping cart
down the stairs and then falls out a
window and Creed throws up and like
something it's some big thing and I'm
just like we shot that I have no memory
of that I I don't remember like what
month it was what year what season is
this it's crazy how little of 200
episodes over nine Seasons that I
actually remember oh I remember what do
you remember what what you're like I hit
save on the middle I know I'm with you I
only did threes into my show eight 24
episodes that's barely anything yeah but
when I watch it I'm like what they were
on it or my talk show is a better
example oh yeah yeah they were again
interviewed I interviewed Ricky Gervais
on my talk show sometimes I'll be in a
bar and there's a basketball game on and
I'm like I interviewed that guy because
Nick Bernstein our producer had a good
nose for who would be a celebrity so I
interviewed a lot of like
pre-celebrations
yeah anyway so what what did you
definitely hit save on I say think close
your eyes let's do it as a meditation
yeah
you're walking into the set
what day is it I remember
uh who's there John Krasinski
[Music]
we added the raspberry I know I like the
feed home 's raspberry
raspberry every time he looked at the
camera and no one had a problem with it
and just guessing no director Steven
Merchant was like that was better that
was wrong moving on moving on uh I
remember me and John in the conference
room hanging balloons uh and I think it
was Mindy taking a nap under the table
and then I remember doing parkour and
running around I remember the parkour
cold open that's a late I remember uh
being on the slack line that was kind of
fun the slack line when you greased the
floor
I don't know did this did that happen I
just remember being on a slack line
shooting on a slack line what's a slack
line that's where the you hang up this
giant ribbon and you try and balance on
it it was season nine you probably
didn't no I just re-watched but this is
how your experience actually is
incredibly in line with our experience
because we'll re-watch it and I'll be
like I don't remember this I remember
Scott's tots yeah because that episode
you're like that's like the episode of
succession that recently aired that we
were all like
Scott's tots is like that it's like
shaving with a very fine razor last
night's episode of succession did you
watch it last nights the stuff with the
marriage of Tom and shiv it really hurt
me and I actually
you know for me watching television is
kind of part of a business and I also
love it I just I love television and
film and I still I when I watch it I'm
11 years old and I'm eating popcorn and
I I can I'm able to turn off that
critical voice a lot of the time yeah
but it really deeply affected me I know
you mean it hurt me in my chest you
realize okay without any spoilers but
this season is the season we realize
we've actually been had meaning the
writers and creators of that show have
got us yeah they grabbed our shirts and
they leaned Us in for three seasons yeah
only to start not just punching Us in
the face like that that's too cheap yeah
but we're at their Mercy yeah they can
hurt us yeah and I don't I mean I said
last night you can break our hearts I
said last night to my friend Mark I said
there has to be a conversation right now
that succession is the greatest
television show ever made with this
season because this season is
astonishing it's like they've done seven
episodes with seven hours it's seven
hours of the quality of who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf I agree and that is
amazing can I tell you something
hilarious yeah so a friend of mine
um she won't mind Ariella she'll enjoy
the name check my friend Ariella was
telling Val my dead mother
um she brought her back into Seance
that's a call back if this gets clipped
Ariella was telling Val I can't get into
the fourth season the succession and Val
goes when did you stop watching and she
goes
um the wedding where they like just went
on a boat and I'm like where is this
going and I turned it off and we were
like you could want to keep watching
that episode like go ahead and go ahead
and turn it back on you [__] grade a
dingus because you you left Coachella
before the reincarnated incarnated
Michael Jackson moonwalked onto the page
like you left at the dumbest part you
could possibly leave yeah as an actor
you'll appreciate this
here's how to act like any character any
of the children on succession uh ask me
how the deal is going listen how is the
deal going I don't know uh [__] maybe
we shouldn't do that yeah so you have to
say [__] while you're thinking yep
and yeah at the end so you go and they
all do it and if you're a Roman you go I
don't know [__] we could uh jizz on a
hippo yeah yeah that's good they all do
but here's what's brilliant about it
they're siblings yeah of course they
were talking and siblings do the same
thing and they all got it from their dad
and when when I started working with uh
Judd Apatow we started talking uh Val
and I noticed
um Judd gravity that the people closest
to judge Judd one of Judds laughs as us
he just bursts like that started
noticing everyone that worked at Apatow
laughed like that I was like there's a
gravitational pull so these guys it's
not even a criticism of succession in
fact it rings true yeah like the way
they all say [__] off and the way they
all go even shiv which my impression of
shiv is this
she's so expressive tell me tell me you
be Tom yeah and say you hurt me more
than anyone
she have
you have heard me more than you could
ever possibly know
okay Tom
here's what I love I love that's good
it wasn't as good as this you know where
it was too much setup there's too much
setup I agree it was better up here the
uh what I love is the way the siblings
hug it's just so great oh I like if they
if they hug they're like and they're
coming in but then it's yeah it's
awkward and it's oh and it's stiff and
it's and they kiss it tolerate the touch
Jeremy Irons
Jeremy Strong [__] Jeremy Strong is
literally imploding season four his
physicality he's but then he killed I
love them
we're expecting the presentation on
living plus to bomb yeah spoiler alert
it's a mild spoiler I think that's fair
game spoiler yeah fgs and he killed
he killed yeah and he's even surprised
at his ability to do it and
he even Fields a question about the
Tweet really well uh we're just two fans
talking we'll have to air this one soon
I I'm totally with you in fact going
back to Judd that was the main thing he
taught me making a show and as a writer
I think you'll I hopefully find this
interesting is that he was like
would go like and then Kendall goes up
and of course he eat [__] and then Judd
would always be in the room and he'd go
or he kills it it that was that's the
voice of The Bard they're they're going
like or maybe it works yeah like that
that's that's the voice of surprise yes
entertainment is surprised yes so if
everyone's going and of course these
prediction prediction comfortable
prediction prediction surprise yeah and
that's what successful predictable
predictable surprise even with shiv and
Tom remember before that and they did
and that's the other thing why do you
want them to get back together you do
though I do and why do you kind of want
I want love again I want more Connection
in the world and you kind of want camera
people to succeed and you want Kendall
to get the company at the end yeah you
kind of do yeah we'll see what happens
yeah we'll see what happens it's
interesting I'm not trying to force us
back to Spirit we can wrap up you want
to go
I got nowhere to go oh I just I I didn't
know if I was reading I was looking
around taking a look around just want to
make sure
we good this is shiv we good
I'm not saying too many faces I'm saying
she's easy to read Malcolm Gladwell
would say she's incredibly matched did
you read that book no which one of that
was um talking to strangers oh yes
because all actors are matched meaning
when I'm angry I'll go and when I'm
happy like it's good yeah you know who's
the most matched [__] in the
world Billy crudup that dude you know
how that dude feels watch him in
anything he's in he's incredible I think
he's deeply wow maybe not I'm the first
time Billy crudup has been mentioned
mentioned on a podcast I feel like it's
a credit
it's a credit free zone he's not getting
mentioned on podcasts I saw him in a
one-man show in New York and it was
unfucking believable it was just him
talking for two hours but playing
multiple characters anyway more of a
brag that I see theater than anything
about him
bring it back to Logan
succession
Angry God Vernon hmm you're the sons
it's a bad prodigal son it's like you've
left and I won't take you back yeah and
and okay skip ahead if you haven't seen
succession but like what are you doing
listening to this just put on the audio
of succession if you're on a road trip
like don't listen to this but um
remember Kendall does the bad thing and
then that's what his father uses to like
feel worse love that's the whole thing
I'll kick you into hell he's holding him
over hell there's that Jonathan Edwards
talked about what a horrible image of
God that God is the hand holding us over
a fire and we're a spider in his hand
and we keep biting him and he wants to
dump Us in the fire talk about a [__]
up
I mean [__] wow but when I watched
succession I'm watching a show about I
think everything's a show about what do
we do with our guilt the guilt that we
exist that's your I'm enough yeah God
doesn't want us to Me Maybe that's your
Christian underwear showing above your
waistline but for me it's just the the
Buddhist tradition of life is suffering
which actually in Nepali is dukkha life
is dukkha and dukkha is chronic
dissatisfaction yeah and I relate to
that more than like
guilt and I've certainly had guilt and
certainly had shame but
um uh
living uh has a cost and it's often uh
negative and learning you know the
Buddhist says I teach one thing and one
thing only suffering in the end of
suffering and I relate to that because I
think humans are wired for Duca we're
wired for chronic dissatisfied I wake up
and I'm like oh I didn't poop and why is
my coffee cold and that guy didn't text
me back God damn it and and I'm I'm
frustrated and things are not enough and
I'm and I think that kept us alive for
eons I think being chronically
dissatisfied and feeling like things are
just not enough kept us alive in our
caves you know we it kept us away from
bears in the bushes that wanted to eat
us and it kept enough deer jerky in our
caves to Keep Us Alive through the
winter it also kept us out in the caves
risking the Bears to get the deer jerky
yeah because we were unsatisfied with
just berries or whatever it might be
yeah so that so so now we're in the
modern world filled with Comfort all
around me and there's Starbucks pods
over here error and I've got a beautiful
backpack to hold my stuff and I've got a
comfortable cardigan and I had a
Starbucks from my app this morning that
I that I just pressed a button and I
walk in they're like good morning rain
here's your drink and thank you so much
and I think that's because you're famous
that app does not work very well I'm
just I'm just kidding I've never used it
I've never used it but um no they have
the app thing down
but you're not the test subject I want
no no no no no uh I'm a Hollywood
elitist yes um traipsing around in my
Tesla
um but uh how do we live come from
non-attachment yeah uh how do how do we
navigate that you're saying my guilt of
Logan is a little bit Christian uh fear
and you're saying you're more
dissatisfaction yeah I think
I I love and I respect and I really
truly love and admire how you've been
bringing it back to this father-son
approval dad God forgiveness versus
Grace prodigal son thing and I get that
and that is a Christian mythology and I
for some reason my personal mythology
goes a little bit more with you know
with the Buddhism even though I'm up a
High
um you're a behudist yeah can I say
something yeah that's brilliant I come
to teach one thing and one thing only
suffering and the elimination of
suffering
that's it that's what you said earlier
too it's through I have to show you that
you're suffering I have to show you that
you're insatiable we tell we say that to
our daughter all the time baby want is
like a monster I give her an ice cream
and she's like I want another ice cream
I'm like I know we need to learn that
there's always another want behind that
want it never stops so can I just
interject one quick thing in the Baha'i
tradition Abdul Baha the son of the
founder talks about cream
um raising uh children and says allow
your children to become accustomed to
hardship it's one of the central
teachings wow and that's one thing that
we've lost culturally I agree I don't
want to expose my children to any
hardship when Val listens to this she'll
be
nodding so hard yeah because I'm with
you guess what disappointment happens
and guess what we always want a second
ice cream cone that's right and we live
in a culture that tells us you can have
that second ice cream and you can
because there's an app yeah and there's
credit if you don't have the money yeah
I understand yeah it's crazy so I I
continue I just think to to
um
step beside the ego instead of losing
ourselves in it we have to first
acknowledge that we have an ego and that
it's insane
and that its whole system is insane and
then we can extricate ourselves from it
and and awaken a spirit and then live as
such and then kind of re-sidle up to
your ego but no longer identified at it
but I can still be like hi I'm Pete
Abdul Baha from the Baha'i faith also
says he came he came to the United
States in 1912 and a journalist met him
and he was like oh here's this Persian
Prophet they called him and they were
and he said uh uh do Baha'is believe in
Satan and Abdul Baha said yes
he said oh tell us what's the Baha'i
view of Satan and Abdul Baha said Satan
is the insistent self that's it yeah and
uh well done and I love I just love that
too because that's dukkha yeah that's
duka that's the chronic dissatisfaction
is my insistent self that's right so how
do you get out of insistent self well
you can address the wants and needs
right like you talked about with your
daughter and you can also address the
self which is what we're talking about
with the ocean and the waves yeah
because
there isn't there isn't a self there is
and there isn't a self and I can be
reminded of that and I'm like oh I'm
just an I'm a wave on the ocean and I'm
going to plunge back into the to the
depth and beauty and Majesty of all this
that's right that's right and the
insistence part I can release my
insistence into into breath and being
yes and to your point earlier that
beauty and art and Opera and
conversation I believe my language would
be our reflections of that Divine love
it's as close as we can get in the
illusion yes but that means the illusion
is a classroom we don't illusion's too
strong Illusions metaphor doesn't mean
it doesn't exist it has a reality it's
just not what you think it is well in
the Native American spiritual tradition
and wakan Tonka from the Lakota Sioux
which means the great mystery it
translates literally as the great
mystery God which I love that idea the
great mystery then you know the great
mystery through name sure so how do you
so people mistake oh they're they're
polytheists because though they're
worshiping they're doing this prayer to
the Sun and they're doing this prayer to
the wind and they're doing this prayer
to the snow or whatever they must
worship all these separate things no
they're all facets and reflections of
the Eternal they're all metaphors in the
sun we get what we get heat but it can
also kill you it's powerful it's life
nourishing it's warmth in the ocean you
can drown in and
um so you have a relationship with all
of these beautiful metaphors and they're
all ways of understanding the one Cosmic
Oneness and when you realize you are
also one of those metaphors that Pete is
also a character in the dream that who
Pete isn't dreaming the dream the self
is dreaming the dream and Pete is also a
character that also helps me say Pete is
enough that's also why I'm like you
couldn't have done better we don't have
to go back to that I'm just saying I'm
going like that was enough because Pete
isn't where the story ends
that's just that's not even really the
Hadith from the from the uh Prophet Ali
from um
the disciple Ali from from Islam is you
know life is a dream and when we die we
wake up yeah and uh father Boyle quotes
that too yeah I love that yeah
so that's interesting going back to that
original point we were talking a little
bit about morality and then we'll [__]
off
okay what time is it
you know why not because you sighed but
because I realize we've been going
pretty deep and it's at it's you know
there's a great you're gonna love the I
think you're gonna let me use your Wi-Fi
for my other interviews
yeah
be okay with that
Katie doesn't live here
it's not like a teacher a dog has been
asleep this whole time you [__]
we have been saying the most profound
[__] plus succession look at that can we
hear the camera I'm just kidding
um can you film him and cut that in I
forget who said it but someone said on
the podcast they're feeling about trying
to understand God was trying like a dog
trying to understand the internet so
those were both of the things that you
do I quote you saying that yeah okay I
quoted you in my book I think saying
that I might have well did I give you it
might have been me but in many
interviews I'm like yeah to eat home
says like a dog trying to understand
it's beautiful I can't believe I made
the rotation what a thrill you know man
I was going to take us into non-duality
in the point of morality is to help us
wake up and I really just want to
remember who I am and it's just too much
can you tell me the time you laughed
really hard in your life the time you
laughed the hardest in your life
and if not there's other rapid fire
questions we can close on
I'll give you some hints okay maybe
someone fell
maybe someone farted I know
maybe someone [__] their pants
oh I know
um how about an office blooper that you
just couldn't get throughout yeah I mean
I watched you do one listen listen
unbelievable
the office the office bloopers are great
um John Krasinski and I
um hanging the balloons and it says it
is your birthday period when we're in
charge of the party planning committee
for that episode
and he's like you couldn't even put an
exclamation point like well she didn't
cure cancer and the brown and gray
balloons like we laughed so hard for so
long at that the set decoration of the
room with the balloons just hanging
Brown and gray just like inner Spurs
like the nothing festive about it
whatsoever like they had to shut down
production they shut it down for like
half an hour 45 minutes because we just
could not get our [__] together
and it was that was one of the times I
laughed the hardest it is your birthday
period is so funny yeah yeah and like
you I can't believe I I can't remember
it specifically but I believe you so
that was one of the times yeah that was
one of the times truly great yeah have
you ever seen the UFO
I have not but gosh I so believe in UFOs
have you been listening to high strange
the podcast no listen to hi strange by
my friend Payne Lindsay a Tenderfoot TV
um they do all the great podcasts it's
about UFOs and it goes into Roswell and
it goes into sightings and with Pilots
like the main sightings when I was when
I was a kid did you see the thing on Joe
Rogan where the woman the model filmed
the UFO out a plane window and you see
it going by no
oh my God it's incredible Jamie can we
pull that up
[Music]
oh sorry I'm not joking wrong podcast
wrong podcast
um I so believe in UFOs yeah and it used
to be when I was growing up people in
the 70s and 80s talked about UFOs they
were tin foil hats nowadays if you don't
believe in UFOs and if you don't believe
that they're an alien technology you're
you're the tin foil hat wearing cuckoo
that's interesting the second part I
would have I was surprised by that yeah
they feel like they're confirmed by the
Air Force like they've been declined
they have they have dozens and dozens of
the most stoic
sober life yeah yeah life committed
military men who gets his buzz cut
refreshed every morning yes Super Cuts I
take a number six and then a number nine
and don't you do that sir you have these
guys saying like I don't know what I saw
but I saw 12 Tic Tac shaped objects but
isn't one of the theories of the 12 Tic
Tacs belong to like Russia or something
isn't that like another they don't how
you're talking OSHA can't even watch it
watch it I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding Show's huge they can't take Bak
moot you know of the Ukraine and they've
got Tic Tac technology that can go from
here to there instantly all right China
all I'm saying is I thought the Skeptics
were saying yes they exist but they're
Earth Technology because the
implications that they're alien
technology that's that's 10 times as big
as just UFOs how they in in every way
they exceed every technology that and
they freshen your breasts and they only
have one and a half calories yeah how
about this you ever see a ghost
I thought I saw a ghost when I was a kid
and my my house was haunted in
um what in Nicaragua
so I lived in Nicaragua as a child and
uh I think it's on your list it is
Nicaragua um it was a funny thing what
does Nica mean because agua is water
here's here's a funny thing you don't
know Theo Von's dad is Nicaraguan did
you know this no and he's from
Bluefields Nicaragua where I lived for
three years as a child shut the [__] so
I've been texting with Theo like we need
to go to Bluefields Nicaragua on a
pilgrimage yes which is another thing in
my book Soul boom why we need a
spiritual Revolution I talk about the
concept of sacred pilgrimages it hit
number four on the New York Times five
close well after this podcast okay
if it had been on this podcast five
years ago it would have absolutely
that's a seller list that's true
so we moved into this incredible
Victorian house in Nicaragua and they
said of to my father o Senora this is
really haunted house and he's like okay
so we moved in a bunch of little Baha'is
here in the late 60s and um every night
my dad I was too young I was like four
so my they would hear this
[Music]
noise from all over the house and he's
like what the hell and then he would
notice like things were just a little
different
and so my dad took a chalk a piece of
chalk and put circles around every leg
of the furniture around the house went
to sleep sure enough that night middle
of the night
he got up every piece of furniture had
been moved between two and six inches
and had slid
so what my dad did what any good Baha'i
would do is he went and he said a bunch
of prayers for the dead and the deceased
he didn't know what to do but he did his
own version of like a Baha'i exorcism I
guess and it just stopped and that was
it it never happened again
that's it I wish I had a better no I
wish I had a better blow this story you
stop it yeah every part of that
Perfection yeah in fact this is Brendan
Fraser's Oscar for the whale
whoa
it's yours now
you can do that yeah kind of stimulating
your the tip of your penis with it
that's my prostate
I just [__] myself with Brendan
Fraser's Oscar I just realized that's
definitely happened I'm not trying to be
funny someone has put that
in fact the designer of the Oscar statue
they had that in mind people want to get
[__] because you're not going to do
that with a writer's Guild award have
you seen what those look like God help
you they're like a Romulan bird of prey
that's how you get the Oscar out you're
like oh it's too deep and great I got it
writer's Guild award
or worse I have to win one now oh and
there is no writer's Guild right now
we're on hold unless it's settled by the
time
judge Judd enough
dead laugh yeah no his is it was like
that okay
you have to be Bigfoot of my lap haven't
I done enough for you that's my jet
impression I feel like we were friends
dead any chance you get you make fun of
me
that's it there's a little Adam Sandler
in there I don't know maybe they're
friends so you can see in their comedy
that oh yeah when they're roommates or
something yeah exactly yeah so you can
see that they both do kind of like uh
Sandler just does it at 10. here's the
uncoolest thing for any comedy person to
do is talk about God
and here we are here we are riding
tanking our careers by talking about God
and religion and spirituality I'll add
to this we are talking about Soul Spirit
life love compassion prodigal son and
peppering it with you get [__] by your
Oscar and wedge it out with the writer's
Guild award I love that but who is this
for I think it's just us and everyone
listening you're a special group we love
you and we do thank you for
participating and go read Soul boom and
God damn it read the bassoon King if
you're if you're like this is too heavy
just alternate between rain Wilson and
comedy sex god and you've probably
already read that you can rest both when
is your next book coming for Christ's
sake we're on strike right now can you
write it please I'm actually I'm working
on a movie that has a spiritual
undertones that's okay next venture I I
do want to write another book but the
problem is I'm in a place where my
spirituality keeps sort of Shifting so I
can't it's not still enough that I can
go that's how I feel I'm like I don't
know how much of this is gonna stick in
three years well I felt that way so when
covid hit I was like now is my chance I
know I'm not going to do a whole lot of
acting so let me get all this down uh
all everything I kind of know think feel
wondered about delved into around
spirituality and vomit all about all of
it out so throwing spiritual spaghetti
at the wall and seeing what sticks yeah
that's what I tried to do in Soul boom
well I'll tell you this why do we need
it I read everything except the last
chapter
it's very Al Dente a lot of it sticks
right thanks Pete and I also say
um I would never burden you with like be
my friend but I feel like every time we
talk we have fun I when you call me for
just a quick cue we end up chatting 35
minutes always love talking to you and I
would so here's what I would like for
you to do it's like if I go back and do
television I would like for you to
produce the show oh my gosh because I
really admire you so much gee I forgot
you talked about that idea yeah yeah
I still remember my version of it I
don't remember exactly where yours left
and mine was about a fallen like could
there be a sitcom about a fallen
preacher who's for moral improprieties
has been fallen and his daughter moves
in with him yeah and she's had her own
version of it so you've got these two
Fallen Angels but gritty but like in the
Roseanne in a Roseanne or mom said I
work in class see when you say that now
I understand more clearly why you didn't
immediately light up at my pitch because
my pitch was that you worked at a
Superstore and the way it's discovered
that you you were a former you're just
like the Kook yeah oh and it was
discovered that when somebody finds your
my old book in The Bargain Bin I like
that though that is good there's
something in there there's something in
that it's so good I don't know if we
should put it in the podcast
you think someone else will I think this
will be good because the comments will
be they'll go from like rain Wilson is a
prick for not liking Ayahuasca [__] you
yes and then it'll go from that to like
you guys should totally make that show I
mean it's on the table and This Is Us
registering that idea with the writer's
Guild so that's right good luck yeah
your dog is still asleep he's been dead
for 20 minutes okay if you could make
that joke about my mom this is dead as
Val my dead mother
um Rainey Wills
can we cut this into the
yeah
into the YouTube version yeah yeah send
that to Joe
um
also I want to talk to you about doing a
soul boom podcast but I want to do it a
little differently and I want to figure
that out because this podcast is is a
tricky business these days it's a weird
world well now and also
it can also be miraculous yeah if you do
it right I'm trying to figure that out
and write apparently means be incredibly
famous when you start it
I've tried that no one watches them oh
I'm sorry you thought that was well I'm
not incredibly famous I'm just kidding
of course well I'm not moderately famous
but I did this metaphysical milkshake
I would yes no I know I was a guest yes
I was just trying to make fun of you
babe I didn't remember that Will Arnett
and those guys oh yeah we were murdering
it yeah but they're killing it but
that's that I actually rescind that
they're doing a great job and my
bitterness that I just
stepped aside and away from is like it's
because they're famous it's like oh come
on relax everything's fine
yeah they're famous and they're funny
that's what I mean and they've hit a
sweet spot of
there's a billion super famous people
that tried to do podcasts and it didn't
work so it's stupid for me to say
they're famous that's stupid no one
listened to I think Barack Obama and
Bruce Springsteen did they have one I
think they had yeah real and it had like
a thousand downloads no one wanted to
listen to oh Barack Obama on Bruce
Springsteen talk about the American
working man like Mulan that's hilarious
yeah it's like somebody told me all you
need to know about it was my agent Zach
trucker he goes all you need to know
about the state of Television right now
is um Sean Penn and Julia Roberts have a
TV show and it's on Stars
everyone's sold up yep it's hard to get
a show on you have to be Julia Roberts
and Sean Penn yeah well we'll keep
talking and please I'll I'll lend my or
maybe Kendall does a great job to your
show any day uh [__] you know right
okay yeah
um rain we could do a show about you
being a pester [__] people love it
yeah
I mean let's let let's end on that you
have to say keep it crispy keep it
crispy all right
believe me
[Music]